if passion could save the planet climate
change would have been fixed decades ago
[Music]
young people are leading the movement
for change look at this young people are
banging the drums there's so much
happening outside and if only people
would listen to this it's incredible if
we don't have to know then our planet
could be in
real danger the leaders arriving in
glasgow couldn't have failed to notice
the voices on the streets and at climate
summit that clamour followed them inside
the un cop isn't like the elite talking
shops of davos and the g20 here the
world that's grown or is growing rich
from fossil fuels is confronted by its
peers who are suffering at their expense
so i asked to you
what must we say to our people
living on the front line
in the caribbean
in africa in latin america in the
pacific
when both ambition and regrettably some
of the needed faces at glasgow are not
present
what excuse
should we give for the failure
but the delegates here knew that the
political realities of getting 197
nations to work together on a climate
pact meant failure was always a very
real prospect
the uk government orchestrated a raft of
ambition raising deals to cut coal
methane and aid for fossil fuels and
mobilize cash
they may cut a few tenths of degree of
global warming important but a sideshow
to the main event
delivering on the paris agreement and by
some measures
to focus minds president obama a veteran
of paris stopped by
we are nowhere near where we need to be
yet
for starters despite the progress that
paris represented most countries have
failed to meet the action plans that
they set six years ago
and the consequences of not moving fast
enough are becoming more apparent all
the time
apparent or not many countries who
depend on fossil fuels seemed happy to
ignore them at the negotiating table
we wouldn't admit it in public you must
have your own comments
not serious allegations these are
fabricated allegations they are
fabricated allegations
in the final hours of the negotiations
china india and others made the move
many had feared
so something's definitely going on here
the plenary was meant to start an hour
ago yet instead despite alex sharma
trying to call countries to order to sit
down and begin the formal process
they broke up into huddles negotiations
are going on
and everyone's looking around trying to
figure out what on earth's happening
their play was to defend coal and fossil
fuel subsidies ruthless but it belies
some important realities phasing out
fossil fuels too fast would be unjust
take ukraine which pledged to end coal
by 2035. at the same time it's not an
easy process
we have
65
of people who actually rely on subsidies
from the government for the energy
poverty they cannot afford their bills
and with the
fluctuations on the market this year
it's extremely difficult it's it's
extremely difficult for many people
in the end alok sharma had to go against
the science and the demands of young
people
i also understand the the deep
disappointment
but i think as you have noted
it's also vital that we
protect this package
the deal was weakened but not destroyed
and time had run out i propose that this
decision be adopted as amended
hearing no objections it is so decided
it is exactly what the demonstrators at
cop 26 had worried about and the deal
also failed to secure the funding the
most vulnerable countries needed most
it's a death sentence
for the poorest people on the planet and
not only that the polluters are saying
to hell with you we don't care we're not
going to give you a penny
so very disappointed
i'm not disappointed i'm angry
as you can see
no deal was going to dismantle late
stage capitalism and close the gap
between the global north and south and
the one agreed here doesn't even cut
emissions by enough or agree to
compensate those who are going to suffer
as a result it's a feeble compromise but
it's not a failure
the pact signed here recognizes we're in
an emergency and it does lay the
foundations for what the world plans to
do about it
i feel very hopeful i mean at the
beginning of this process two weeks ago
i did not think we'd get this far i
think at the very end there was a little
bit of a wrinkle and that's hard to
swallow when it's so emotional
everyone's in the room together and and
it's very heavy it feels like a lot but
if you told me two weeks ago that we
would have got this i never would have
believed you and i'm very heartened by
the way that the whole world has come
together because they recognize they
need to do more for climate action and
keep 1.5 degrees in sight
in sight but still far from reach
they're packing up this vast climate
negotiation road show before it moves to
shameless shake in 2022
if the ambition there is even greater
than it was in glasgow we could be in
with a chance
albeit a very small one tom clark sky
news glasgow